حلفوا الدبابات الكبيره هكذا اسمه سفير
كيف في برلين بعد ان انتهت باين بين الدول
الغربيه بخصوص ارسال اسلحتها الثقيله
الهجوميه الى اوكرانيا
باعلانها ارسال دبابات ابرامز المتطوره في
الاشهر القليله القادمه
اعلن اليوم ان الولايات المتحده سترسل 31
دبابه ابرامز الى اوكرانيا اين يعادل
كتيبه الاوكرانيه
في العالم كما انها معقده للغايه من ناحيه
التشغيل والصيانه لذلك سنوامن لاوكرانيا
المعدات اللازمه للحفاظ على فعاليه هذه
الدبابات في ساحه المعركه
شكرا لم يتاخر
وفي تغريده وصف الخطوه بالقرار القوي الذي
من شانه ان يغير حسبه من معطيات المعارك
ميدانيه
اما بارين التي تعرضت لضغط كبير طيله
الايام الماضيه فقد انهت هي الاخرى الجدل
باعلانها تريد 14 دبابه اليوبار اثنين الى
اوكرانيا كخطوه الاولى لدعم كيف في حرب
هذا الدروس
اوكرانيا
المانيا والولايات المتحده فان بريطانيا